hello in this screencast I'll be showing
you the new chemistry features we've
introduced across our journals on nature
com allowing you to make the most of our
articles online this new functionality
allows you to access a host of
additional resources whilst exploring an
article we've also enriched our articles
with information about chemical
structures to start let's take a look at
the various ways of viewing compounds
and related data within an article
scrolling over the bold numbers for a
compound in the text brings up a pop-up
box allowing you to quickly view its
structure each compound has its own
individual compound page which can be
accessed by clicking on the bold number
but more on that later alternatively if
you want to browse through the key
chemical structures in the article
simply scroll through the compound tab
here in the right hand navigation panel
under inside this article clicking on
view all will direct you to the compound
data index page listing the key
compounds in that article from here you
can go to each chemicals individual
compound page or download all of the
chemical structures in this article in a
single chem drawer file if you're still
hungry for more compounds you can view a
selection of some of the key compounds
from that issue of the journal by
following the breadcrumb trail back to
issue and clicking on the compound
roundup link on the right hand
navigation panel
now let's have a look at what's on the
compound pages by scrolling here on the
right hand navigation panel
the compound pages provide key
information about each compound such as
their name synonyms formula molecular
weight and elemental analysis
when a paper is accepted the articles
chemical compound data is automatically
deposited to the pubchem database this
data can be viewed by clicking on the
link to pubchem from this compound page
the compound structure can be downloaded
from this page in any of three formats
as a chemdraw file a CML file or a mol
file chemical identifies such as inches
and smiles are also displayed these can
be used to search for chemicals online
and can be converted to the 2d structure
by many structured drawing programs back
on the compound pages you can look at
the compounds in 3d zooming in and out
and rotating around the structure like
so
we're available further information and
data supplied by our authors is also
displayed on the compound pages for
instance you can download the
crystallographic information file for
this compound and for this compound the
synthetic procedure and characterization
data are displayed under the heading
synthetic procedure the bold compound
numbers in the synthetic procedure
section worked just like the ones in the
article text so you can hover over the
numbers that refer to starting materials
or products to reveal their structure
and also click on the links to go to
their compound pages in this way you can
follow the chain of the reaction you're
interested in finally if you want to see
the original version of this procedure
and the full experimental details you
can return to the article and find these
in the methods section or click this
link and go straight to the
supplementary information names of
compounds mentioned in the text of an
article are annotated with structural
information and links to chemical
databases you can choose to view the
article with the compound names
highlighted by clicking here
clicking on the highlighted name allows
you to link to pubchem and chemspider
where the chemical structure and further
compound information can be found to
wrap up I'll show you a few other
features introduced on H com to allow
you to make the most of browsing and
viewing an article online figures at a
glance have been included at the end of
each abstract allowing you to quickly
scroll through the images or structures
within that article clicking on a
thumbnail enlarges the image and
includes the figure caption
enhanced reference linking both within
and at the end of the article allows you
to view citation details more easily
within this article if you hover your
cursor over a reference in the main text
a pop-up box appears giving you the
citation details of the reference within
the references at the end of the article
reference context allows you to view
within this section the area of the text
where a particular reference is cited by
clicking on show context clicking on in
article highlights that reference number
in yellow in the body of the text in the
supplementary information section you'll
find not only a PDF containing all the
extra information and figures but also
raw data files such as these
crystallographic information files where
available so that was a quick overview
of the new chemistry tools on nature
calm have fun trying them out